are you hoping that a Super Smash Bros
game will make its way to the switch
well it's probably going to happen at
least that's according to Nintendo of
America president Reggie fils-aime a I'm
Matt this is a GameSpot news update and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe to stay
up to date on all of the Nintendo switch
games
Fiza may appeared on a live stream with
Katie linendoll and said smash is
obviously one of our best-selling
franchises what we say is that the
philosophy that Nintendo has from a
development standpoint is that for every
platform we want to have at least one
each of our classic franchises there's
going to be one great Super Mario
experience there's going to be one great
Zelda experience so you can anticipate
at some point in the future who knows
when that all of our franchises will be
addressed
we know that the fans love these games
love this content so stay tuned huh I
wonder where that Metroid game for the
Wii U was a Reggie the Nintendo switch
launched last week alongside the Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild which
received a score of 10 out of 10 in game
spots review you can check that out on
gamespot.com but if you want to see it
in action for yourself check out our
video on the nine things we wish we knew
before starting breath of the wild
[Music]